[Music]
you and I both have something in common
which is we both get told that we
resemble female actresses is this true
yes I don't you tell us who who you feel
you resemble I don't feel like this but
you can be the judge I've been told by
multiple separate strangers that I look
like Laura Dern in Jurassic Park so not
like not like you look like Laura Dern
you know from Jurassic Park no like I
look like we're a Dern only in Jurassic
Park from that okay let's take a look
here I'm just curious and to see like
[Applause]
I don't see it you don't see it first of
all everybody sees it now if you look at
that first of all her mouths open my
mouth is not open okay yeah that's right
you're wearing a denim shirt you're like
you know what I get all the time yes
Tilda Swinton and we actually found a
photo of Laura Dern and Tilda Swinton
together this is a real photo and you
see if that looks like the two of us
what do you think I it's it's it's us
yeah it's our future I think we both
have similar problems where I feel like
I could recognize you just from your
skull like if they were like if there
were ten skulls in a row if they're like
I mean if I after I'm gone if that was
just a skull you could look at my skull
and say that's Conan I go I think I'm
the same if there were ten human skulls
I'd be like normal spell normal skull oh
look Conan's go a bunch of stone so my
only be guys going like that we'll be
right back after these messages
mine would just still be talking Andy I
would know your skull anywhere ya got a
big melon right right right
mine would just you'd think it was a
pumpkin
you